[Music]
okay looks like we're alive hello ladies
and gentlemen I'm
Ilia and I'm here with grand Master's
Choice the topic of tonight's lecture is
going to be punishing positional
mistakes where we're going to be looking
at mostly my games but also occasionally
mixing mixing in games from other
Grand
Masters oh it was a video haha gotcha CH
steroid
anyway we are starting off with my game
against uh left pasor kovski I believe
this game was played in in the US Open
of 2018 if I'm not
mistaken uh and over
here this position by happens happened
from a one of the lines in an English
opening right so I played English with
E3 and uh um if you guys do some digging
or or looking some looking at my my
games in the database you will find out
that I've played this one many many
times and the tricky the tricky part
about this line is that after reaching
the positioned and after facing the move
Knight captures
F6 um Black's main response should
really be to capture back with a pawn
which is a really difficult thing to do
and un you know precisely what's going
to happen right because there are couple
of couple of lines that may seem quite
scary from the outside right so black is
supposed to be playing in a very
aggressive manner there's a move D5
which I believe I faced a couple of
times but then the main line goes with
black playing
E4 uh and eventually what's going to
happen is I believe that black or or I'm
going to be sacrificing my knight this
way right so utilizing the open G file
I'm basically going to be claiming that
I don't really need the Knight I would
much rather have an open G file and then
I would follow through with uh with
attack against the black
king so um as we all know the engines uh
make this look like an easy draw
claiming that most things black black
would black do here will be just fine
and everything is going to end in the
draw and everyone's going to be happy
but but in reality um during a practical
game unless you
know the precise defense it's going to
be very tricky to play this is
black hello I Manny welcome so over here
after facing the capture of six my
opponent decided to save himself some
trouble and recapture back with the
queen which is which I already consider
an inaccuracy right because essentially
we're reaching a similar looking
position uh where black is going to have
a long-term disadvantage right so the
pawns are separated now black has two
Pawn Islands right the the G pawn move
the way towards the center black now has
double pawns and F and the H7 Pawn is
separated so this also means that most
end games especially the pawn end game
it's very very likely that the pawn end
game was just simply going to be lost
for black because of this Factor because
more Pawn Islands the separated Pawn on
H7 and the King will always have to
stand near the H7 Pawn to so that black
doesn't lose it
so knowing that I preceded obviously I
still need to get my pieces out right
because as of right now black is
massively ahead in development so I need
to to follow up on that so I played A4
Bishop A5 either Bishop A5 or Bishop C5
would lead to the same exact position
right it doesn't matter B4 Bishop B6 and
Bishop
B2 uh so over here my opponent uh
chooses the correct approach he goes
ahead and plays A5 kind of trying to to
um bait me into into capturing an A5
obviously once I capture an A5 I'm going
to have an you know a separated Pawn an
additional Pawn island of my own right
the pawn on A3 becomes weak and so it
makes it you know a bit trickier for me
to play plus was black Bishop returning
to A5 I'm going to have some I might be
having some issues uh in the center so
wasn't quite you know looking to do that
uh at the same time I can't really
defend opponent on B4 right if I if I
play Bishop C3 here that's that's going
to cost me a pawn after an easy tactic a
takes B4 a takes B4 Rook takes C1 Bishop
takes C1 Knight
B4 and I lose the
pawn so all that being said my Pawn is
under attack I don't want to take I
can't defend the pawn with Bishop C3 so
the only other reasonable or logical
decision would be to play B5 which is
like what I did my opponent let Knight
E7 and I played
D4 um D4 is a move that that immediately
attempts to to apply some pressure in
the center right now uh as I'm as I've
just began attacking the E5 I'm I'm I'm
no longer I no longer need to worry
myself about some F5 f4s right now the
F6 Pawn is stuck in place because black
has to keep defending the E5 if black
makes a critical decision right because
playing E4 would be a critical choice
right solidifying the pawn structure now
I can likely reroute my
knight to one of the Outpost
uh F4 seems pretty pretty good to me or
maybe even somewhere to somewhere to G3
trying to apply pressure against E4 um
you know um I'm not sure
how bad playing E4 would be but at the
same time if you think about it black
can kind always play E4 and they don't
really want to force things unless they
can kind of get something out of
it so D4 yes so uh DM uh you're you're
asking whether D4 is more ambitious I am
indeed behind in development but if
you if we think about what can black
really do uh to punish me for being
behind right the Queens are off the
board so um I'm not really all that
worried about uh my king being attacked
right usually if you're behind the
development one of the biggest issues is
that your pieces start lacking space
which doesn't seem to be the case here
and the second issue secondary issue is
your king because your opponent gets
more pieces out your king your king you
know gets in trouble faster or may
potentially get in trouble so none of
those things are actually the case here
and despite the fact that I am behind in
development I'm actually feeling very
comfortable as as um as I'm I have I
have no weaknesses no real weaknesses my
next move is probably going to be long
Castle right to hide the king bring the
A1 Rook into the game then Bishop Bishop
is to follow and if if black uh can't
really find a way to immediately punish
me for for for being behind
and that that's okay it takes D4 would
indeed open the
position but uh in a in the long run it
makes your makes Black's Pawn structure
even weaker right because now by
capturing on D4 black gets essentially
three Pawn I on right because the F7 and
F6 pawns are now separated from from the
rest of the Queens side pawns and it
makes it more difficult for black to to
do anything with these pawns right if
the pawns decide to go up I can easily
if I don't want to deal with any F4
right they can easily just play G3 and
this this Pawn is now stuck on F5 pretty
much forever I I'm I have strong strong
doubts that black would ever consider
taking on D4 because it gives up a
bishop air advantage right so this is
probably going to be like a Lo like a
last resort for black if if things go
really really wrong but you know um at
this point I'm not really being attacked
right my position is safe my king is
going to Castle uh the very next move
black has once again very very easy
target for my pieces right the pawn on a
five is the main target and I have a
bishop Advantage hello
Damian oh it's a continental
open that's what it looked like to me
did you have a oh oh oh I I might have I
might have gotten it wrong I don't see I
don't see the
tournament where this game was was
played I I I thought it was yes open but
but I could be wrong it's been a it's
been a while
ago so black doesn't really want to take
on D4 and uh over here my opponent makes
um like let me let me get rid of all
these
arrows shouldn't have that many okay
there we
go so at this point my opponent decided
to to play it fast and he he I guess
what he did was an attempt to to force
force me to open things up right so my
opponent went no never mind sorry it's
not here my opponent went A4 which is
the reasonable move although um it's
hard to kind of think about uh the the
the use of this move especially because
well Bishop is clearly trying to get to
A5 but my king is leaving the E1 because
I'm I'm cast wrong right so I cast for
the wrong and now Bishop coming to A5 I
guess would would take away the E1
Square from my Rooks although I'm not
sure if my Rooks would want to go to E1
right because if you guys remember after
black captures on D4 in most cases I I
was going to recapture with a knight
meaning that the eou doesn't actually
get open right so I I kind of have no
reason of to have the Rook on E1 and I
feel like I would much rather have it on
G1 which may may seem a bit strange but
my idea one of my ideas is definitely to
to do a a run on the G file once again
it's a I'm not sure if that's exactly
what I would go for because um this plan
involves me trading off the vak pawn on
F6 right but at the same time I would
you know it would allow me to open up
the G file so just like a
possibility uh okay let's go back yeah
so A4 long Castle over here yeah this is
where my opponent
C5 you were thinking about pushing the
HB yeah I mean I I could I could have
definitely gone for H some H4 but my my
problem with H4 is always that black can
just play H5 and that's likely how far
my my Pawn is going to
go opponent is about to do positional
mistakes they're going to be punished
yeah pretty much yeah pretty much so
here my opponent played the move
C5
okay so uh DM is is saying that he would
assume that doing long Castle would be
um a bit trickier because black can open
things up with C6 by the way the C6 is a
is a good uh um a good attempt I believe
that I i' I saw the move C6 during the
game and I was planning to react with
this once again looks quite scary right
because I'm I'm I'm I'm advancing on a
side where I'm supposedly weaker right
my king is there so I should I shouldn't
be I shouldn't be very comfortable
opening things up but actually this is
this is this is purely a tactical
approach right once we calculate we will
see that this tactic is actually going
to be in my
favor um if black just goes back it
costs him the pawn right because I'm I'm
going to end up winning the E5 and I'm
going to end up winning E5 either way
right so black is going to take on C5
I'm not taking on C5 I'm taking on E5
and now I'm essentially I'm I'm we we
swapped right now black has double Pawns
in the C5
as opposed to having double Pawns in f
file now here yeah black is in in quite
a predicament my my next move is is
fairly simple I'm I'm planning to play
Bishop C4 and I feel like I'm going to
play Bishop C4 regardless of what black
does if Black Goes Bishop
E6 I guess Bishop C4 is still a
possibility although this in this case
black manages to win a temper right so
now black can probably capture on B5 I
would take back with a bishop and as you
can see my king is still Fair fairly
safe because there is nothing going on
on the C file if anything if black tries
to push the C Pawn by playing Rook C8 I
can just block everything with Knight
C4 and then I'm going to try to use my
my uh my king Side Pawn majority
Advantage by pushing the pawns like
so luckily Queen are of the board yes
that's exactly that's exactly why take
the bishop and
zigzag the Knight to Fork things okay
one second so um
at which which position are you talking
about
choid can't we just take the bishop the
well Oh you mean over here oh oh hats
hats off to you Chester roid well very
well done very very well spotted look at
that
although I'm not sure how good this is
let's let's continue calculating right
so oh wait Knight
D5 no still not simple right not simple
right Knight D5 we could definitely
remove a Defender right the Knight is a
Defender if we play E4 black has an
inter has an interesa right The Rook a
d8 and now if I take remember we did
give up a pawn right so if I if I do
this trade I better have something to
show for
it knight5 looks good yeah Knight E5
looks good because because here after
Rook captures D5 e captures Knight
captures B6 Rook d8 the Knight is kind
of stuck and now let's say Rook D1 I was
I was slightly worried here about
something maybe about
D4 no I also I think you I I still
believe that you're smart it's just that
we need to find a way to make it work
although even here these kinds of end
games where you have two light pieces
for for a rook can sometimes get tricky
because Rooks in general Rooks are more
agile in end games as there are a lot of
open files so that seems to be the case
here although actually let's let's go
ahead and see what's going on here with
the help of an engine I'm not sure if
you guys can see the engine oh you
probably can but the engine thinks that
white is better but not like
catastrophically better right that's uh
it says something let's see if we not
missing anything here along the
way no we're not we're not we just we're
just clean but you see you see if you
don't go for it on the other hand if you
just play Bishop captures B5 oh but here
here I didn't make the very obvious move
yeah Knight D7 I should I should be
making Knight D7 with my eyes closed
Knight C4 is is not as strong so I gu I
did manage to find some some stronger
stronger opportunities using the
engine's help been a long day I
apologize I don't see things as clearly
anymore only lasted for 20 seconds you
were it only lasted for 20 I'm not sure
what you mean by that
but this is what would have happened had
black tried to to play C6 and and open
things up so I guess because of this my
opponent was really really afraid as as
he told me after the game he was really
afraid of the C5 breaks through and he
just didn't want to deal with it anymore
he he went ahead and played C5
himself you guys can probably see the
the issue with this move right this move
essentially just kills the bishop but
that was also partly my opponent's idea
to just make sure that the position
remains closed so that his his V King
and and and the double pawns are not as
you know as so if the position remains
closed and and these weaknesses remain
it's not as critical because in close
position I'm I'm going to have a harder
time exploiting
those he pushed C5 that's correct and
this move actually just almost loses on
on the spot so what did I
do with queens of the board I guess it
makes a lot more sense yeah this this
line is also engine proven like this
this this looks like this line just
works because it's a very concrete case
where we are so behind the development
but our opponent cannot punish us right
so it's it's only it's only a mistake if
if you get punished for it right
practically speaking right if you if
your opponent has something practically
to to make our um our decision to delay
development um an
issue can I remind you of what opening
this Pawn structure came from this this
this came from a a a rare opening line
in English um unfortunately I don't have
the whole game here I'm not sure why
that is but uh but this is the position
we started from this is E3 English this
it's kind like the C4 E5 Knight C3
Knight F6 Knight F3 Knight C6 I
played E3 my opponent played Bishop B4
Queen
C2 Castle
short Knight D5 Rook E8 Queen F5 D6 was
a final move and this is how we got
here so let's I hope that helps let's go
back to here and yeah so so I took on
E5 D5 is yes so my concern was playing
D5 was that exactly that thing that I'm
not I don't have uh um I don't have
enough going on in this position to to
make yeah I guess you guys are right we
could we could try to play
D5 with in coming to E4 and F4 yeah
that's true we could try to breach but
once again if you take any E5 if you
guys think about it VR already have a
perfectly placed Rook on the D5 right if
you just take on E5 our Rook is already
in the
best place it can ever be and actually
here um I we could do a little bit of a
calculation exercise about the
possibility of me playing Rook
D6 right because it's it's a double
attack after all and uh if that's all
there was to it then I would have just
be winning by now unfortunately it's not
working right because black has Bishop
C7 Rook captures F6 and The Rook is is
actually trapped on F6 so black I can go
ahead and just pick it up King G7 the
only plays The Rook can go to is F4 and
Knight G6 and yeah my Rook is
gone it does trap The Rook I man yeah so
this was this was my opponent's
masterfully crafted trap unfortunately
for him I I'm completely disinterested
in in in going for any any
tactical bouts you know I all I want to
do is I want to EXP the weaknesses right
so the weak Pawn on
F6 um I've been thinking about how to
get to it I the the G4 G5 plan crossed
my mind right G4 taking advantage of the
fact that black can never take right
this guy is gone after
H3 um but then I realized that maybe I I
I could I could do it in a more
effective way because G4 black can just
allow me to play G5 right G5 takes takes
and then what what did I really do right
I freed black from
from from from his double
pawns D5 E4 and Rook somewhere on the
third ring looks okay it does look okay
but but but we're actually just going to
be winning here straight away so while
the the plan was just keeping the things
closed and then slowly bringing in the
pieces to kind of trying to slowly
suffocate black could work but at this
point we are already in position where
we can take immediate advantage of
Black's weaknesses right we don't have
to play the slow no more right we can
just take on E5 and then go Knight D2
correct that's what I did you guys can
probably see the notation I assume right
so you guys can see what happened I
played Knight D2 with transferring the
Knight to E4 and my knight being on e4
is actually a pretty big deal because
from E4 it can sometimes go to D6 it's
applying a lot of pressure against the
F6 Pawn so my opponent just did not have
to uh you saying Knight D2 Knight G6 and
F5 five is coming I'm not sure how
you're going to play F5 here so I'm
going to play let's say Knight
E4 yeah yeah so at this point I'm I'm
threatening to take I'm not sure what
what the defense is like I think you're
just losing the pawn at least right so
wait no I I'm not threatened to take no
no no no I'm not because there is a
there's a black and block let's check
right so rookie six is
there so I'm not threatening at that but
I might be threatening something else
let me see well plus what is what is
going to be your next move so I can I
can actually just take it at this point
I can actually just go ahead and play
Bishop E2 and politely ask you okay
what's your next move sir go ahead and
and make your next move it may seem like
F5 is a good idea but I think in a in a
in the long run it's probably going to
be more detrimental to Black than
anything right CU I play Knight D6 let's
say my next move is going to be F4 I'm
going to be continuously applying
pressure and when things going to get
open up my pieces are better accustomed
to the change my pieces are going to be
better accustomed to to the pawn trades
in the center right I just have better
pieces black actually has this Rook on
on f8 on A8 that's absolutely nothing
the bishop is stuck on C8 right Bishop
is unable to move because B7 is always
hanging so at this point I just have a
better prepared pieces
for the trades right so if I play F4 I'm
going to then trade on E5 play Rook F1
F5 is going to be in
trouble looks bad for black it's just
matter of technique yeah yeah most of
these positions do look extremely bad
for black but um at the same time there
are still some things black can do right
so just like my opponent who played
Bishop
F5 basically putting this idea onto a
hold asking your opponent what's your
next move so's also helpful helpful
technique to gain time on the clock and
give them the possibility of making a
mistake yeah uh usually your most of
your WI are going to be coming from the
your opponent your opponent's side right
so your opponent is going to be the main
the main cont contributor to towards
your Victory right it's it's they they
have to they have to go wrong somewhere
right if you if you keep asking them
questions if you keep giving them rope
right they will
eventually that's that's that's what we
should be striving to do right we should
be striving to apply so much pressure
that our opponent is going to be
continuously stressed out and then it's
not it sounds pretty bad right what
we're doing sounds very mean but that's
how that's how chess works we are all
really nice guys in real life we we we
the nicest people in the world but when
it comes to to playing we need to be
extremely mean right we need to keep
telling our opponent okay you can't do
what you want right you you we're going
to yeah we're going to make or hopefully
we're going to make our
opponents why a living hell while they
play during the game not outside of it
free free
rope
okay G4 now that's correct so now we
just essentially once again using the
fact that black can never take on G4
because there's always going to be a pen
with Rook G1 so Bishop G6 and H4 now the
black s squ Bishop is in
trouble um honestly my opponent I would
say kind of panicked here he he played
he played H5 right uh the move
H5 does what I've been trying to do
just without me actually having to do
anything right I've been trying to open
up the G file and uh it I was actually I
was ready I was fully prepared to play
G5 to do that I was fully prepared to to
red black off of their double pawns to
do that but now I'm getting it I'm
getting it open up without even having
to trade the blacks double pawns away
right that's that's a
win-win we have a mystery person here
who who is a mystery
person okay okay I'm not sure who you're
talking about I I can't really see
myself anywhere the screens are all dark
I'm I'm nervous I don't know how I look
like on screen I don't know might yeah
there's a here oh oh okay
okay you would imagine it's a strategy
primarily used by a stronger player
against the vaker player though right I
don't think it would make a lot of sense
to use that strategy against a higher
rated
player well no I mean if you if you it's
it's a strategy that's used in a
situation where you
uh are in command it doesn't it doesn't
it doesn't have to mean that you're
stronger it just have has to mean that
what it means is that
you you are at a position of knowledge
and you have more understanding than
your opponent doesn't have to you don't
have to be stronger you can still play
someone who is stronger than you you
know rating wise or or or he's stronger
than you in a certain type of style but
if you get them into a place where
you're very comfortable and this this is
definitely one of those cases then this
is how you this is how you win
right would you make an exchange of
exchanges wait what wait what what do
you mean exchange of
exchanges you mean after Bishop captures
H5 would I would they play Knight
E4 is that is that what you're asking
Bishop H5 did not happen I was planning
yeah I was planning to go on e4 that's
correct but I think I think I can get
more than just than just exchange of
exchanges because after King like it's
hard to imagine where the king is going
to go if it goes to f8 I actually have
this check now and I'm going
to I'm going to make it really difficult
for black to figure out where the king
is going to go as it goes to G7 I can
take on E5 otherwise I can take on B6 I
can check on G1 there's a lot of things
going really well for me here so I don't
have to take on E8 I can even here I can
even go ahead and play Rook G1 right
because there's actually no maybe not
there's Rook d8 yeah so that will be
that will be a bit too much but there
are a couple of other things he can
do hi all just joined what position of
mistakes are we focusing on well so so
far this is game number one uh black did
make a big mistake or a couple I guess
the first in accuracy U um um black made
was U getting double pawns and going
going into an end game with it and then
the second inaccuracy that oh second
more of a mistake that happened was
black playing C5 and essentially killing
off their dark s Bishop while also
allowing me to to have my pieces exactly
where as I want to be right so in this
case um I
can put a lot of pressure against the F6
Pawn as well as the D6 Square by just
bringing my KN over to E4 so my opponent
felt like it's a bad idea to let to let
it happen he played Bishop F5 and after
G4 Bishop G6 H4 I kept following the
bishop with my pawns uh H6 would have
been you know a slightly more sturdy way
but after H5 Bishop H7
F4 captures captures the funny thing
about this is that even if black manages
to defend this Pawn somehow which which
by the way is going to be very difficult
to do without playing F5 let's say King
G7 now I have two very cool ways
probably to just end the game right away
I can play F5 which what was my original
intention F5 just kills the black's last
Bishop now black is playing down a piece
because they can never get the bishop
out or G5 G5 would be another another
way but not doesn't look as cool and
yeah it may it may win me a pawn let's
say but I would much rather have my
opponent's pieces dead dead to rights
than you know having them alive and
kicking and here even though I'm
probably still objectively winning
because I have an extra pawn my pieces
are still better than blacks but you
know when your opponent's pieces are
able to rejoin or able to come back to
life then you know anything can happen
you can screw up so you you you better
just make sure your ponent pieces are
unable to move period so you don't have
to worry about anything till the rest of
it thanks for answer answering the chat
questions wait what am I not supposed to
be doing that what why do I have the
chat box open then all right so H5
happened G5 would have been amazing yeah
G5
G5 would be good
enough oh F5 okay yeah F5 okay so H5
happened and here once again my opponent
did not take on H5 he played Bishop to
H7 I guess just really committing to his
Bishop remaining on the on the on this
diagonal to stop me from playing E4 but
once again I just basically told him
that okay well at this point I'm already
up material right I'm up a pawn my
Bishop is coming out onto a long
diagonal I'm beginning to attack B7 my
opponent does not have counter play
right there's not I'm not being attacked
so if my opponent keeps losing material
without getting anything to show for it
I'm just going to win just going to
capture I'm just going to catch them all
right just like the Pokemon song So Rook
a B8 and Knight to E4 despite the fact
that it's going to force the trade right
I'm I'm getting the bishop pair
Advantage it's still it's it's a it's a
crushing Advantage right I have so many
ideas to make progress I can play a or
to break the pawn chain and open up my
Bishop I can I can play Rook G1 followed
by H6 and Rook G7 there's just too many
threats I now now I'm beginning to
threaten Rook D6 right so many things
for black to worry about so my opponent
as a result ended up losing very quick
quickly after King G7 Rook G1 check King
h8 and Rook D6 and it's basically black
is almost getting M it right I pick up
F6 and Rook H6 is a Checkmate threat so
um my opponent decided that it's it
would be be pointless to try and survive
here and he resigned after move
25 that's right the white the S Bishop
is putting in a lot of work controlling
all the important squares the F5 the
H7 so
yeah this guy's looking too much about
Chess for my taste what okay you guys
want to want to want to have some some
uh some life story it happened in 1972
no okay no I I'll leave that to yaser
yaser yaser does yaser tells Amazing
Stories you guys should if you guys
didn't watch any of yaser's San streams
I strongly advise you to watch some some
Recaps because yaser is just an amazing
human being he has he has wonderful
voice Amazing Stories to Tell a lot of
experience is a chess G Master as well
so if I were to choose which streams to
watch yaser streams
anytime okay so this was game number one
how am I doing time oh my God I'm doing
horribly as as as always I apologize I'm
taking forever so you know let us go
ahead and move on to the next game it's
probably going to be the last game I
show you guys but you know hopefully uh
hopefully it's going to be useful for
you as well so over here another game of
mine uh I was playing International
Master Eric
andarius and uh in this position
Eric um oh maybe I should maybe I should
keep the uh maybe I should keep the uh
the notation hidden from you guys oh
that's that doesn't sound like a bad
idea see on screen oh they can't because
I can see it on this screen okay so
nobody oh okay oh never mind then all
right I was think I was thinking that
maybe it's going to be a good idea for
you guys to uh to see what what went
wrong so Eric in this position played
the move Knight G5 I'm going to remove
these arrows in a second there you go so
the move Knight
G5 was kind of eyeballing a couple of
ideas right there's Knight takes E6
there's Knight E4 trying to to trying to
Fork my pieces and maybe get a bishop
pair Advantage right so what do you guys
think the problem with this move was
let's see if you guys can figure this
one
out do you remember where this game was
played this game was played in
Philadelphia interational of
2019 if I were to
guess I see Queen H6 I see Queen G6 well
the move yeah so first of all let's
address these responses one by one right
so if Queen
H6 uh this to me this looks like a a one
move threat right you're threatening to
to take on H2 so what
if black just goes
H3 right I I'm I'm really not seeing the
followup plus what she did really is you
you placed your
queen on a on a discovery right there's
a discovery possibility right your queen
has been x-rayed and uh now you probably
have to move it away so I would say that
the IM man's suggestion which is to play
Queen G6 might
be a little bit what how people are
saying more more sensible but at the
same time it's probably actually wors in
Queen H6
because you guys are missing Bishop
C2 right and as you can as you can tell
it's probably even a bigger issue than
than having the queen on H6 now Queen G6
no Queen G6 does have a threat kind of
right the threat is to play something
like H6 and and politely ask the Knight
to to retreat right we are we are after
all applying pressure on G2 but
obviously Bishop C2 just kind of ends us
right F5 this is not this is not the
kind of complications we want to go into
right we're yeah we are uh we are
definitely an underdog in in all in all
these complications you're losing a pawn
and what for
right so
any other
suggestions Queen H6 and queen queen G6
good tries but not very effective
anything else you guys can thank
of Rook a to E8 looks natural Rook 8 to
E8 does look natural but what about the
Knight
E4 would he be
okay
um giving me a a bishop pair Advantage
although you're not you're not quite
doing it right because you have Queen G6
and I can't really take on
D6 okay that's better Rook A8 is is a is
a better option I would say but are you
sure you want to use the A8 rook and not
the f8
Rook would because because you need to
have like plan for your other Rook too
like I don't I I have really strong
doubts that you would be happy with it
being stuck on f8 right
C5 looks interesting yeah it does but
yeah white can just take and then a
bunch of white pieces are hanging
yeah that was my second question okay
yeah if if I you if you are trying to
play Rook E8 you could you could do it
just using the f8 Rook right just Rook
E8 Knight E4 is isn't really a threat
right because we have we always have
Queen
G6 but if KN wait if Knight E4 is not
it's never really a threat wait wait
wait wait hear me out so Knight G5 so V
just V just kind of unintentionally
decided that Knight E4 is not really a
threat what about what about Knight E6
come on think about this guys what is
the thread of KN G5
again is it 96 is it 94 which one is
it what is this move threatening can
white let's make a Dem move can white
can white take
here
look at this takes takes and oh no we're
losing the Knight but who cares about
the Knight
right yeah F2 is hanging Knight E6 no
not a threat right that capturing E6
just loses the game for white KN E4 not
a threat kn6 not a threat so what in the
world is KN doing on G5 how about we
just poly ask it like why are you on G5
what are you doing there and by the way
I tricked you guys yet again because
night
E4 runs into another tactic by the way
you guys will probably be very very
surprised to learn that at this at this
point Knight E4 is the best response for
white my opponent realized that the KN
actually doesn't have a good place to go
to right now and play Knight H3 and this
this was the first
real positional mistake Knight G5 was an
accuracy right because after Knight G5
white can still be okay but what's there
there is something wrong with Knight E4
as
well I guess this is what my opponent
got afraid of and because of this next
sequence tactical sequence Knight E4 was
not played and yet practically speaking
it was probably why's best chance at
this point what did my opponent
Miss Bishop takes H2 well Queen
H4 right Knight just Knight takes D6
removing one of the one of the attackers
so Bishop takes H4 exactly King takes H4
Queen H4 check double attack King goes
back Bishop takes E4 there's no tricks
why does not have any tricks to win our
Bishop on e4 G3 runs into Checkmate on
H1 right and yet this position still
provides white with the best practical
chance because white does have a bishop
air advantage right so if white plays
his cards well enough we're going to
have something like this happening well
where even in the end white is just down
a Pawn but because white has a bishop
air advantage they do have some some
sneaky little threats that we would have
to deal with and looks like white should
be able to survive in the long run right
a single Pawn is not it's not big enough
of an advantage to claim black is
winning
now uh you're a little bit behind but
C5 okay one sec
C5 so we have to probably go all the way
back to to look at to look at C5 right
this this is the place okay so C5 DC and
the queen takes
C3 is the uh the
question let's
see I'm I'm I'm not seeing tactics very
well tonight guys um what I do see is
that we have a couple of easy like if I
just don't want to
calculate for white what I could do is I
could just play Bishop E3 once again I
don't know if I might be missing
something I don't see what I'm missing
yet but there there might be something
I'm missing I'm just connecting just
connecting these guys whatever piece
takes on C5 I'm going to take what
whatever's left right so if Bishop if
black Bishop is the one taking a C5 I'm
going to take on D7 if the Knight takes
an C5 I'm going to take the
bishop
so there no Queen H5 would would be very
tragic and right to uh to White's
Ballade I'm not sure if that's a word
but I think Bishop E3 is just simple I
don't see why it doesn't
work I'm going to cheat and ask the
engine engine proves my suspicions it
does work plus three so there you have
it you didn't see Bishop E3 yeah um is
there any is there any other way no oh I
found the best move oh oh actually no I
I felt like I felt like this could also
work but I just did I just it feels like
it works because we have a lot of pieces
right where they need to be auction the
queen gets trapped look at this oh my
God all right uh
yeah it wasn't very difficult but I feel
like just winning a piece would be less
comp complicated to
see engine probably doesn't recommend
quein H5 yeah yeah that's
true so over here Knight Knight G5
pointless because can't go can't go
right so after H6 even though white
should have still played E4 or gone back
to F3 my opponent decided to misplace
the Knight and put it onto H3 and here
came uh another very important moment in
the game because
um the White Knight being stuck on the
edge is White's only issue so if I don't
address this if I don't take advantage
of this issue fast enough white will
find a way to bring the Knight back into
the game so for example like G3 Knight
F4 or F3 Knight F2 so the Knight is
going to return to the normal squares
right so I need to make sure I I'm
keeping that guy there for as long as
possible queen queen G6 once again runs
into F3 and this is where the Knight is
going to actually now it cannot even get
back in from F4 once you play Queen G6
yes we we did um no we did Force white
to play right F3 it's like playing F6
right if you guys know um um Ben fow's
suggestions He suggests to never play F6
or F3 respectively right depending on
which side you're playing
from it's it's kind of like that right
F3 is not a very useful move here it
does vaken white king we can maybe look
into some c5s now right as as the
diagonal is vened we can try to open
things up from that side so not bad but
we can do better and let me show you
what I did
I played the move Queen
H4 very important move in my opinion
this move allows me to never play F3
even if it's made in one yeah I've heard
stories about people just following his
advice to you know to the
ward actually not giving check Maiden
one because it's it's
F3 um the Knight won't move now exactly
that's exactly the point now I'm just
want I just what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to make sure the Knight is out of
the game for as long as possible so I
can make maximum out of my other pieces
right if I begin attacking like my
attack is very very likely to succeed
now as the Knight is so badly placed on
H3 so let's so let's see what happened
um um for some reason I have F4 here I
guess F4 is well this is not the I'm not
sure why I have it as a Mainland because
this is not what happened in the game
but this is something that white should
have done instead of what they did in
the game
so F4 once again attempting to bring the
Knight back even though actually it
doesn't do that right because F4 is
hanging and this is why Queen H4 is such
an important move because I can just
proceed with Knight
F6 and once again my plans
are but they're not limited to Knight G4
and C5 I'm pretty sure I can do like
other things like maybe A5 A4 and and
maybe applying pressure against F4 so a
lot of things going well for me here
once again Knight F2 is impossible for
now for the time being because of Bishop
captures a four
this loses for white immediately right
on a spot Queen G2 and Bishop F3 winning
the
queen what if F3 here but we
just we just we just gone over it right
F3 is one of those moves but what what
are you exactly trying to do with F3
you're not trying to play Knight F2 are
you this is why you have to play F4 if
you're trying to move the Knight back
you have to block my dark squ Bishop
otherwise you can't right the H2 is
hanging
so F4 was actually White's best try here
but my opponent instead
played Rook
B1 I gave it a little bit of a think
because there is some Bishop takes E6
hanging in the air but then I quickly
realize that I can just let it happen
Bishop takes E6 is going to run into
what response let's see how how well you
guys see tactics what you I think I
planned
here my Bishops are like Marshal Bishops
but I'm not down a PA yeah exactly
exactly this is why I love this I love
this position for me plus I was also had
in time a lot so the game was just going
as well as it could have
been we take the bishop
and no no no no wait one sec you say
take the bishop and queen
G4 no no no no Queen G4 leads to an even
trade right you can't you can't plus
you're losing the bishop on B7 remember
that's the part of the tactic white
wants us to take because then they
they're picking they're missing Bishop
back
immediately Bishop E4 or Bishop G2 which
one which one of the two you guys you
guys basically all found the two
critical responses it's either Bishop E4
or Bishop G2 right which one is Bishop
G2 isn't that good you want to take on
G2 but then see the followup okay so you
guys are all voting for Bishop E4
then Asis I'm going to I'm going to try
to come back to your question in a
moment just uh uh just going to try to
to finish things here with this tactic
so okay I'm going to take it I'm going
to take it as you guys saying the bishop
before is correct and lo behold you
found a way to lose the game
congratulations because after
G3 the queen is
trapped and the only place our Queen can
go back to is H5 which leads to this
trade and then this trade and in the end
of the day we are
missing two Pawns in this end game not a
again Yes again yes yes got
him and the bishop G2 that supposedly
has no
followup is the correct way because
despite the fact that there might not be
an immediate
followup look at this guy this King on
G2 is so so
bad it doesn't even
matter that we are not technically we're
not up anything we're going to be
winning material there's no way this
king is going to survive our attack let
me give you an example Knight E4
attacking
F2 so a logical decision would be to
defended actually it's hard to do even
here because we also attacking the
C3 if white tries F3 we have a enormous
tactic which is Bishop takes
H2 now F takes E4 just very very quickly
loses no we don't even have to take on
C3 Manny we don't even have to because
we are checkmating we have three pieces
attacking it's enough because of how
exposed the white king is it's enough we
don't need no more Rook G6 trying to
stop us from playing Queen G3 but we
said we say no we want to play Queen G3
no matter what takes here Queen
G3 King H1 and just H takes G5 with our
next move being Queen H3 moving the
bishop and it's just
checkmating then that's
s hello my myaro
welcome okay so uh let's go back to um
to uh can I wait I cannot scroll the
chat as yeah unfortunately you can ah
hiya okay well we lost the question the
AIS I believe it was was the name think
I can find it yeah yeah the question was
something yeah he said you you can't
sack a pawn to free your knight with F3
D5 and after black takes with the pawn
then Knight f
well okay so F3 F3 D5 so is this the
position that we referring to let's see
maybe here
F3 but how how is D5 going to be helpful
I'm not quite sure so because D5 will
will just take right this bishop is not
getting
blocked right
well right I I don't really see
how how this this sacrifice would help
us free up the Knight right so doesn't
look like it it's unless you're talking
about some some other position as these
if so do let me
know okay so this is why after Rook B1
Knight F6 I was really not afraid of
white capturing on
E6 this was not still not too late to
try and play F4 I guess or F3 but my
opponent didn't didn't want to do that
he just did not want to create any
weaknesses in his position whatsoever
thinking
that the Knight on H3 is okay and is
going to be fine and it's it's it's
solid right now and hopefully it's going
to remain solid until the rest of the
game so we made couple of normal looking
moves because I can't really win
anything immediately I didn't want to
play n G4 well well here I can't right
because check might didn't one duh but
uh I think at some point I could but
yeah it's just F4 white can always play
F4 and kind of defend the H2 so I didn't
really want to play n G4 at any moment
because I felt like my knight could be
used for some other maybe even tactics
involving the E4
Square you to peanut butter yeah that's
unlucky all right well
next okay Bishop
D2 C5 right so going back to my original
idea of of breaking through in the
center was C5 Rook D1 Bishop C7 now
Bishop C7 was or not not yet over here
here I got a little bit carried away
because I saw my Bishops I was like oh
my God my Bishops are great I want to
play like you know like uh um what is
what who who was the the inventor of
this of this famous double Bishop
sacrifice um
um oh my God I'm
tripping the
um it has a name I just forgot but yeah
I was just trying to make the the double
Bishop sacrifice work it's a very very
famous um tactic
um yeah and I decided to invest into it
because I went ahead and played Rook D5
trying to bring in more forces right
bring my Rook over to H5 and then once
my Rook is on H5 that's definitely going
to work Lasker sacrifice okay I I I'm
going to believe
you so Rook D5 this wasn't necessary I
all I had to do was I could have created
another weakness right so when when
White's position I could have created
this weak Pawn the isolated Pawn on D4
and I could have just kind of started
playing against it maybe even by
doubling on a dile
so I tried to to go for it for a pretty
end and thanks to the fact that my
opponent was so down on time he was down
like he had like minutes left on his
clock at this point has move 22 so as
far as I remember there there might have
been a different there might have been a
second time control so he might have had
a chance to get additional time if he
reaches move 40 but obviously making 18
moves in the position that's so
difficult to play you know close to
Impossible right so he immediately makes
a blunder blunders the paon on D4 and
now over here I guess he realized he
can't really take if he takes it's just
this just ends it right long diagonal
gets exposed and the game is over so he
did not take on D4 he gave up another
Pawn on C3 and this is where I can
basically conclude the game by saying
that I'm up to pawns my position is
actually still better the Knight finally
came out guys guess what the Knight
finally came out onto F4 it only costed
why two pawns right
and uh yeah my opponent tried some
tactics unfortunately nothing really
works we we traded into an almost an end
game and here uh I realized that white
king is still very weak right uh I can
even even with just three pieces it's
actually going to be enough for me to to
go ahead and uh help myself to the king
and the King after making a a glorious
March all the way down to
H6 unfortunately was
brutally murdered by my
pieces and that ladies and gentlemen is
probably going to conclude
my relatively short but hopefully
informative lecture on how to punish
positional mistakes right two we looked
at two examples today the first example
was about my
opponent creating weaknesses in his
position and then
further making his situation worse
by closing the position down killing off
his pieces you
know making it more difficult for
himself to create a cter play in this
case it's once again about the the
opponent help giving you a helping hand
by misplacing one of his pieces so badly
that it
backfired it's a Greek gift no not quite
because it's a double Bishop sacrifice
GRE gift is just a singular Bishop
sacrifice like H7 or H2 and then you
follow it up with a knight check and the
queen comes in so it's not it's not
quite the same good games thanks for the
lesson well my pleasure I hope you guys
enjoyed enjoyed this uh this short
lecture and uh yeah be on the lookout
for for more streams I I I do appear
every now and then and uh yeah there's a
lot of there are a lot of other very
very interesting people streaming on the
you know St Louis chess club's YouTube
and twitch channel so do make sure you
you follow the channels to stay tuned or
to to stay informed about the upcoming
streams and on that note I'm going to be
Bing you guys Fair
so good night good day take
[Music]
care